bonjour ligne
[Musique]
j'ai de bonnes nouvelles à ce jour vous
avez terminé le niveau qu'un une fille
puis embrassent leur licence
le niveau 16 sera votre dernière année
avec thalys
qui parie aurait une super famille
système rpt a une fille pure à carreiras
ou soeurs il est de notre responsabilité
de signaler les comportements un pur une
fille pure est toujours en forme et tant
pis si tu dis à quelqu'un que je suis un
pur
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
wasquehal et moi
ok
le niveau 16 n'est pas comme les autres
niveaux
je vais tout faire
ma confiance tu dis que tu as fait une
crise d'asthme sévère tu pouvais plus
respirer
je me demandais je fasse disparaître
cette voiture j'espère que tu sais ce
que tu fais on va tous y passer alors
c'est moi qui vais m'occuper on s'en va
tu peux me dire ce qui se passe
ça renversé maturi va ses fils du baron
de la drogue que j'ai envoyé en prison
ce crime ne peut pas rester impuni
c'est toi qui a renversé son fils y tu
seras plus jamais en sécurité nulle part
tant qu'ils remontent jusqu'à lui il
aura fait disparaître les preuves
pour attirer l'attention qu'on peut on
est tous dans la justice pour servir
quelque chose dans ce trophée lave
l'honneur de la famille on commence par
lui
dans quelle merde tu nous a foutu
[Musique]
je suis robert le boss 23,7 leurs deux
guerriers dans les yeux vous devez
vraiment apprendre à contrôler votre
tempérament il causera votre père
oh
tout top
qui rapportera la tête de robert
lellouche recevra la somme de 50 pièces
d'or aux
cela
vous le combattre et à mort de troy il
n'est pas mon roi
c'est robert bruce
il se cache ici
fouillez de photo co quand quelqu'un
viendra pour tuer le roi il faudra se
battre
nous avons connu les cosses sous
l'emprise d'une main puissante
maintenant nous la libérerons tu meures
rejoignez vous dans ce combat
[Musique]
dix mille épouse dit me lemaire nous
savoir que nous sommes ne sont pas morts
enfin
l'écart qu'on est
ne perdez pas espoir
c'est n'est que l'on gens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression qu'il appartient à
quelqu'un d'autre
ce bouclier représente un tas de choses
pour un grand nombre de personnes
[Musique]
les symboles ne sont rien sans les
femmes et les hommes qui leur confère
leur valeur
nous avons besoin de quelqu'un qui
ranime notre flamme
[Applaudissements]
tout est plus compliqué maintenant
on ne s'arrêtera pas
vous n'avez pas le droit de nous rejeter
du monde vous pourrez plus faire machine
arrière
on n'a pas besoin d'aller à
l'affrontement carli
c'est le seul moyen
[Musique]
on n'a pas le droit de perdre
que ce soit clair
[Musique]
on va régler ça à notre manière
on est d associer décoller sans que ça
fasse de nous une équipe non
mais avoue qu'on a quand même la classe
[Musique]
le monde nous ouvre des horizons
la vie avait d'autres projets pour moi
je veux faire du grand art et je veux
faire beaucoup de bruit
mais avez-vous l'instinct de tueuse
c'est une question primordiale je
l'espère de tout coeur
[Musique]
ah ah
oh
je suis femme
entendez moi rugir
je cours c'est le moment d'envoyer de la
musique d' alléger l'ambiance
c'est très belle
wall a dû trouver maman
manon
les petits monstres gros bisous pas prêt
oui chérie sais pas ce qui se passe avec
ton téléphone tout le cabinet de
chercher
[Musique]
parti sans laisser nous il n'a pas pris
de faire il répond pas au téléphone mais
faut lancer un avis de recherche
on va voir fleurir votre vie privée et
professionnelle mais j'ai rien à cacher
marc espérons que votre mari non plus
[Musique]
[ __ ] mais on disparaît pas comme ça
sans raison si vous avez besoin de quoi
que ce soit en peignoir si vous savez
quelque chose c'est le moment ou jamais
et vire de bord bien sûr qu'il va
revenir ma chérie jeudi 18 mars
inédit gloria une création tf1 retrouvez
dès maintenant l'intégralité de votre
nouvelle série sur sept au point fr
ce péché mon père que d'espérer un grand
amour quand je déciderai tu pourrais
génie notre mauvaise fortune en espagne
pour un compact
mieux vaut mieux attendre pour viser
mieux alors voilà toute la sphère deux
en l1 immeuble paris ce serait pour vous
forme d'accomplissement comme ça il ya
la boucherie toute leur vie rente et ont
subi un seul césar gens qui voudraient
deux mois s'ils ne restent pas tous par
l'argent que peut inspirer au bonheur
je suis charles devant des fils de votre
frère si vous le souhaitez cet après
midi je vous emmènerai voir le pays
volontiers vous n'avez jamais quitter
ces lieux
parce que vous croyez qu'on m'y autorise
je vous montrerai paris un jour enlevez
vous tous la tête et puis tu connais
attin
on jase beaucoup en ville sur la façon
dont vous traitez votre fille ce que
l'idée rapide pour ashok pas un lit
armes sortir de ma poche pour acheter un
mariage à ma fille et enfin de vous
sortir avec mon neveu pour faire courir
les rumeurs les plus folles dans son mur
elle va devoir partir qui ne verra plus
jamais
puis les pontons de ne rien attendre
pour une femme si ce n'est la volonté
des hommes de tous les âges
la marine
aucune société d'un créateur de
fréquenter une femme seule croyez vous
que j'en ai besoin de cette société
[Musique]
les bbox se prétendre au sein d'un petit
ami décédé il ya cinq ans hésite ou
cesse
tu sait jamais
mon amour la raison n'a pas sa place
21 soirée brian cox
mercredi 14 avril à 20h40 strange picchu
inédit
et à 22h15 churchill sur 6 10 il
retrouvé à la demande
la série succéssion avec brian cox sur
ocs
[Musique]